[Music]
if there is one thing I can guarantee
you is this if you are way too sensitive
way too sensitive and you were raised in
this family where your mama told you
you're so perfect and no one's ever
going to do anything wrong to you and
you decide to go into the world of
business BAM you're going to say that
hurt and you're not going to stay as an
entrepreneur because in a world of
business it can get very very ugly at
times and I'm simply trying to
emotionally mentally prepare you for the
beatdown that you're gonna get if you
become an entrepreneur so today I'm
gonna talk to you about eight bad
experiences that will help you as an
entrepreneur so let's start off with
point number one here's point number one
a very very embarrassing and humiliating
experience that you had what could that
be I don't know what it is but it's got
to be very embarrassing it's got to be
very humiliating it could be you going
in school and you're trying to play
football and you go to tryout and you
play basketball and you're so
embarrassing you're so embarrassing that
everybody laughs at you that moment of
laughter you will forever remember if
you have that moment of laughter if you
have a moment where you wanted to go out
there and try to play a certain game or
try to go talk to a certain girl or try
to do something and you were so
embarrassed so humiliated that that
stays with your spirit that's actually a
good thing because in business it's
going to happen many times so if it
hasn't happened yet once and it happens
in business you're going to say oh that
hurts I'm not going to do that again and
you'll leave second one being bullied
it's very important to be bullied here's
why it's very important to be bullied
and I know a lot of times I did a video
once called the how to handle bullies I
think the video is called how to handle
bullies and I cannot stand bullies if
there's two affirmations I give to my
kids every night I come home I ask them
two questions daddy did you bully do we
bully people no do we get bullied no
both are answered no one we don't bully
anybody
- we don't bully people I expect four
things for my
kids lead people improve daily love and
improve that's it those are four things
simple but we don't bully people but
it's the best thing that happens to your
wife
my younger son gets bullied by the older
son
the younger son gets pushed gets hit
gets all this other stuff when he
becomes 14 years old and he gets him to
fight with a kid you know how my younger
son's going to handle it is unlikely to
have a fight my older brother four years
when you're nobody to me
let's go fight what do you want to do
you want to fight let's fight Mario's
got a younger brother right your younger
brother Mario so many stories David
right Martinez told me stories about his
younger brother what what stories have
you told me about him fighting and whoop
this tale knocked him out how old was he
at the time 14 years old why because
David has two older brothers or three
older brothers for six listen he's got
five older brothers do you think that
kid is going to grow up being bullied a
little bit it helps some business so if
you've been bullied before if someone's
put I remember being a kid in Iran I
remember being a kid in Germany I
remember being a kid in high school II
over and over and over again it made me
tougher many of these MMA fighters when
you study them if you study many of
these MMA fighters there's one thing
they all have in common you know what it
is they all said why don't you become a
fighter because I got bullied why did
you become a fighter because I got
bullied man eventually I was so sick and
tired of bully I wanted to whoop his ass
so I became tough and that's why I do
MMA and that guy doesn't fight me
anymore this is not a new thing this is
a very I know this stuff is strange so
parents are not going to share this
video with their kids going to no honey
don't watch this video because this man
this Iranian a Syrian Armenian
scary-looking big man says you need to
be bullied baby don't watch this video
unsubscribe from value tainment right
but in reality it's a good thing that
happens to you next rejected being
rejected is a very good thing you know
why I have a hard time I've been
mentoring salespeople for 15 years you
know what their fear is they see this
they scream like a little girl when they
see if one oh my god oh my gosh hey Jon
this thing you got to pick up and you
got to make phone calls no no yes no
won't do it yes No
why not because it can handle one word
that's got only
two letters in it at least be scared of
a 16 letter word why are you going to be
scared of a two letter word no be scared
of a technical word all they're telling
you is no not interested no no no no you
know this hurts just the last 30 seconds
you listen me say no it hurts you some
of you guys even stop watching a video
because you hate the word no no is good
in business no it's very good in
business because you get rejected then
you get used to it then you know
eventually what happens to you you're
desensitized you know what's
desensitized when you don't even see it
anymore you know the guy that goes to
the ground and says hey you look pretty
girl I want to take you out no okay
Friday or Saturday night
I said no I'll pick you up what's your
address I just told you no cell number
same number because it's the same number
John I told you no just makes you wear a
nice dress all right all right I'll pick
you up boom I don't hear too no same
thing with business you've got to be
deaf to the know the more rejected you
get the better off you're so sometimes I
get these snapchat messages people send
me but you don't understand how hard of
a life I've lit my pad you so you you do
not sympathize with people you do not
understand people Patrick said the other
day that for him hitting rock bottom was
driving a Ford Focus how arrogant are
you to say rock bottom his Ford Focus I
grew up in Iran I was homeless for quite
some time before joining the military
I had nothing to eat many many times in
my lifetime many many times in my
lifetime we had to live on my friends
houses and beg them I used to go and
sell my lunch ticket just to have enough
money to going because I never got an
allowance for six years I never got an
allowance this is this kid never I have
to find my own allowance I didn't have
allowance so don't tell me about like
your life being hard my parents got a
divorce my mother went back to Iran I
don't have a clue where to live I don't
know I don't want to hear your sympathy
story I'm not trying to win subscribers
here if you don't like this channel go
to a different place that motivate you
and tell you how awesome you are but
stop complaining to me about how
difficult your life is we did a video
yesterday on a webinar the guy's on if I
was a private webinar they want this
contest I'm on a call with this cat he
says well let me tell you this what he's
a Sandman kinky luck do you do you make
any decisions are you watching
you think here one of the best things
that can happen to you is being rejected
best thinks so use for some of you that
are watching this that you think you had
a bad life man be thankful for it
because that's going to help you in the
world of business not the other way
around the guy that's been guarded and
protected by mommy and daddy so nothing
ever bad happens to them they don't know
how to handle reality when it happens to
them you do use that as the best thing
on your resume not as a crutch as a
strength because it can help you in a
world a business next a great breakup
man one of the best things that can
happen to the great breakup I don't love
you anymore
what are you talking about I don't love
you anymore I just don't I don't know
what happened I used to love you I just
don't love you anymore
I don't do you do like is there somebody
else yes who your best friend know which
one jack
oh my that's great oh that's great again
Patrick have you completely lost it no I
just know when I talk to people who have
built a very big business and you sit
down and break bread and you really find
out their story it is hell and back
before they build it big and some of you
guys are fully qualified like the weight
just so you know that you just need to
see the strength of it so break up
phenomenal thing let it go break up with
you oh it's so great let us say I don't
love you anymore just remember that date
man that's a magical word right so I'll
go right into the next one China see if
I can remember all the points next one
piercing words oof you know what's the
great thing about piercing words it just
goes boom it goes through you and it
stings man it hurts it hurts piercing it
hurts you know what type of words I
remember one time I'm on a conference
call with a guy who's a guy Tom good
friend of my very good friend of mine
good friend of mine this guy were on a
conference call and a guy on the other
line tells him this on the conference
call he says this to him cuz at that
time was it wasn't doing too well in
business they're doing very good right
now but at that time he wasn't doing too
well on business he's working as a bill
collector he lost everything
the house he bought for his mom that his
mom losing and he has to go tell us my
mom you got to move out because I lost
this house mom mom I lost this house
tears come in this cat cats eyes tears I
remember I remembered this guy okay but
he's a very very solid guy character
solid guy right you know what happens
one time we're on a conference call one
guy says this to him he says let me tell
you something Jose you will never you
will never make it in business you will
never make it in business do you know
how many years ago that was oh wait oh
wait seventeen nine years ago it was
such a piercing word he remembers her
till today he murmurs it till today I
remember certain words still today now
there's a part to forgive 100% but it's
kind of tough to forget there's a part
to forgive but there's a part you don't
forget you remember those words this
thing's got a lot of power lots of power
sometimes a coach or somebody that's
even coaching you may say certain words
to you that are piercing maybe he or she
is testing you to see how you're going
to respond strong coaches are very good
at doing that they'll Belichick you
think he's not going to say certain
things the other day they were talking
about why uh what's the coach of a
Cleveland Cavaliers what's the guy's
name they should though the guy that
came from tyronn lue Tyrone was a coach
of Cleveland Cavaliers used to play for
the Lakers and there was a scene last
year in the season you know what the sea
was so coach Blatt is a coach that came
from Europe and he's a guy everybody
knew and they hired him to coach
LeBron okay and middle of the season
Blatt and LeBron are not getting along
black gets fired
they bring tyronn lue just so you know
Tyrone was shorter than me okay and
LeBron is six a 260 and Tyrone was about
6-1 6-2
give or take maybe 6-3 okay and there is
a scene here's a scene LeBron is coming
in LeBron is coming in Tyrone is going
out in the timeout LeBron starts telling
Tyrone what to do Tyrone who says shut
the F up
now I'm not telling you this is
something for you to do with your
people this is sports in sports there's
locker rooms that's heated it's
different than business completely
different than business but there was a
heated moment he said to LeBron I'm the
coach be quiet I'm the coach
I'm not Blatt I'm the coach LeBron sits
listens
tyronn player player draws up the play
they go they win D game they ask
LeBron afterwards what you think about
that said I respected him for it because
that's the reason why he's our coach and
then they won the championship together
and I was the prior coach couldn't do
that couldn't do that sometimes piercing
words boom hey let's go let's do
something with it
you got to remember some of those
piercing words then when you do get
piercing words it's all about how you
respond to piercing words because
there's two different ways people
respond to piercing words one of them is
what I can't believe he said that to me
I'm just such a loser and I'm this and
I'm pouting and I'm going to my mommy
and I'm crying on my daddy I can't
believe this
we're like you know what let me prove
him wrong let me go out and prove myself
that I can do this they go do it it's
completely on you but the more
opportunities you have like that the
more opportunity you have to just scale
your your capacity just goes I got to do
something big with this thinker you got
to be able to do something big with that
the other one a very very very good ass
whuppin it's a very good thing to happen
to people why you know why let me tell
you why one of the reasons why it's very
good to have your ass handed to you is
because it tells you you're not as bad
as you think you are meaning you're not
as tough as you think you are and you're
not as great as you think you are
there's always somebody out that I can
kick your butt there's nothing greater
than that there's nothing greater than
you walk in on thinking you're tough and
then somebody gets you because you
realize you every single day you're
competing don't underestimate anybody
every single day you're building do not
underestimate anybody the moment you do
you could be the guy that becomes the
next Tyson you could be the guy that
loses and comes back after Golden
State's got the greatest record in the
history of em being there 73 and 9
LeBron James comes back after 3-1 and
they beat you it could happen to you you
cannot walk around like your dad bat
this is why good ass whuppin
sometimes and good ass whuppin could be
in business somebody completely crushes
your new person comes in and crushes you
how you going to respond to that a swoop
and I think I've got I've got one more
two more left right the other one is
going broke going broke going broke is a
very good thing that can happen to you
going broke is a very good thing that
can happen to you let me tell you why
going broke is a good thing whether you
lived in a family that didn't have a lot
of money whether you lived in a family
that didn't have a lot of money or you
went broke I have experienced both I
grew up in a family we didn't have a lot
of money we were welfare family and I
lost everything okay so I experienced it
firsthand when we didn't have a lot of
money and we lived you know this was
pretty tough times and then I
experienced when I lost everything lots
of girl loss all that stuff both of them
I was in a pretty bad state and let me
tell you what happens when you get to
this bad state you get to this bad state
where you're completely all alone by
yourself and there's a part of you that
thinks you're done there's a part of you
that thinks nothing else can change
there's a part of you that wants to
throw in the towel and I'm here to tell
you the way you respond during that heat
at the moment in your life turns you
into the person that gets to creating
losing a habit that lasts a lifetime or
becomes a person that rises up and says
you know what man I lost this hurts I am
hurt I'm a bit depressed I'm a bit
shocked I have a lot of fears but I'm
gonna fight again
and you get up and you fight if you come
back from this and you fight and you win
the spirit inside of you know what it
believes in it believes you can overcome
any obstacle and that's a very dangerous
person to compete against Mike you do
not screw with people like that you just
do not screw with people like that
because those people have a certain
spirit that's backing them up it's very
tough to go against somebody like that
next betrayal betrayal could be a very
good thing it happened to me in business
a couple times one was a person that was
a good friend that we experienced this
and it was a betrayal I was shocked that
if
could do something like this after
giving me their ward shook hand
everything betrayal it's a very good
thing that happened it was a very good
thing that happened because it teaches
you things so betrayal is a good thing
in business that can happen to you
because it makes you judge people in a
complete different way it keeps your
guard up a little bit more to be
paranoid about everybody until you trust
them this is one time when I was sitting
with Mark Cuban a Mark Cuban was asked
you know you have all these companies
that you own how do you manage the COC
says I micromanage until I trust I
micromanage until I trust when you get
betrayed here's what happens your speed
of trust delays when we're not even
we're young kids we trust faster when we
get betrayed now it takes 18 months to
earn my trust you used to take three
months and this is a good thing it's not
a bad thing it's a good thing people
come and tell me Pat I'm gonna be the
greatest salesman you've ever had or
really yeah now I give you two years
let's see if you even mentally and
emotionally tough can't even handle
somebody pushing you that's when I know
you're legit okay because it takes
longer to trust in someone's abilities
it takes longer to trust somebody be a
partner it takes longer to put somebody
in that position that you know that you
know can go out there and help you get
to the next level it takes a little
longer to do that so betrayal was the
last one and here's their a things that
I'm telling you there's a lot of parents
that watch it and parents I just want
you to know this I have some relatives
over had some relatives over and the
conversation was you know all these
things about my dad was telling stories
and it was all these people were telling
my sister all these guys were telling
stories and it was you know we should
have raised in a different way and we
should have done this and we should have
done this and all this other stuff and I
said you know what I kind of didn't mind
seeing my parents argue I said what are
you talking about I said I mean I'm in
Panama with my friend Steven Alfred
we're in Panama and we're driving to
Panama Canal and we're driving over
there it's just raining and all this
stuff I see this four-year-old kid
pushing a shopping cart with a
two-year-old kid in there there's no
parents around it's raining this
four-year-old kid
visually still on my brain my mind till
today four-year-old kid is pushing I
have a four year old son and I have a
son that just turned three that's as if
my oldest son is pushing my two
three-year-old son he's pushing him and
I'm like a god what what the hell was a
parent's where are the parents
what's going on over here and that kid
is four years old in two years old and
he's got somebody watching over and I
mean there's a certain you know we we
are tougher than we think we are man we
got this thing called survival of the
fittest and we got certain survival
mechanisms that are ingrained in our
body that we kind of know certain things
maybe not as much at that age but you
see this sometimes taking place and
sometimes I see parents protecting their
thirty year old son as if they're for
yourself come on man let this guy get
his nose bloody a little bit I did a
call one time for a mother and the son
were on the call together
you remember this we're at the airport
I'm doing this call and a mom's
protecting protecting protecting
protected unlike then him loose he's a
baby protecting protecting protecting
protecting protecting protecting man
there's there's that part NEC Mama's
that raise boys I know one right here at
a Dallas tough guy
two boys three boys we all went to
school I'll get their four-year degree
they all pay for their college mom was
disabled grown-up kid named Jason tough
father wasn't around this guy figured
out a way to raise a younger two younger
brothers but the mom says no excuses get
to work get your acting you better clean
this place I don't want a single
spotless place kind of raise some three
tough boys that they all are survival
right now they're doing pretty good for
themselves this Jason guy made sixty
seventy thousand dollars this month and
he's a quality guy what happened there
so parents are watching this I just want
to encourage you get your kids to be a
little bit tougher teenagers if you're
watching this you want to grow up being
tougher I understand we're living in
this politically correct world where
everything's about sensitive and and
don't say this to your kids because it
may stay with them for a very long time
honestly few scars on you is okay man I
don't want a body with no scars you know
I want some bodies with some scars
put some scars on me it's okay you're
supposed to have it makes you tougher
you last you can hang in this world in
this dog-eat-dog type of world you can
hang and if you choose and truly want to
become an entrepreneur man you better
you get you better get used to some of
these some of these things you're going
to get hit you get cut so don't look at
these ADA experiences bad experiences I
hope you'll look at them as some
positives and I hope it brings up your
spirit to realize you can handle some
bigger things in life such as
entrepreneurship that being said let's
get our pillow here I feel really good
today I feel really really good today
our old pillow of 2016 made it in two
more episodes 4:17 before we launched a
new episode if you have not subscribed
to this channel listen what are you
waiting for click on this button here
it's very easy you can do with your
thumb or you can do with your index
finger I don't know you can even do with
your pink if you want to just go click
on it and then the alert button next to
click on that as well you'll be the
first to be notified because we're
trying to get this channel to a million
subs by the end of the year there's 7
billion people in the world if we can
get more people around the world to
become entrepreneurs men in every single
possible way innovation improves and
makes everyday life better so with that
being said questions thoughts comment on
the bottom I do read every single one of
them thanks so much for watching
everybody take care bye bye
Oh